on la sentait avec une nouvelle
encourageante je vous le disais en titre
le sida semble marquer le pas en france
pour la deuxième année consécutive le
nombre d'infections est en diminution en
2006 une réserve toutefois d'après le
ministère de la santé
les homosexuels restent le seul groupe
pour lequel on n'observe pas de baisse
nathalie sapina à la location oui on
peut se protéger du sida
et oui les campagnes de prévention
portent leurs fruits la preuve de 7000
nouveaux cas en 2004
on est passé à 6300 nouveaux cas en 2006
pour la première fois dans l'histoire du
virus l'épidémie marque le pas en france
sauf chez les homosexuels
un tiers des nouvelles contaminations ou
les pratiques à risques persistent
élément clé de la lutte contre le sida
le dépistage 5 millions de tests
réalisés l'an dernier mais pas toujours
à bon escient pour étendre le dépistage
le ministère souhaite la mise en place
de tests rapides très facile à utiliser
une goutte de sang un résultat en 15
minutes au lieu d'une semaine pour les
tests actuels et une lecture
particulièrement simple une bande rouge
en haut le test est négatif deux bandes
rouges
le patient est séropositif dépister
précocement
oui mais avec un dépistage de qualité et
un suivi des personnes à la fois
médicale est aussi psychologique
ces tests rapides sont déjà couramment
utilisé en europe et aux états unis
ils seront expérimentées en france en
2008 les